[Music]
a second set of human remains were found
at lake mead yesterday this comes a week
after a man's body was found in a barrel
on the lake shore last sunday madison
kimbrough joins us in the newsroom
tonight with the latest in the
investigation madison sasha two sisters
who were paddle boarding near colville
bay saturday afternoon stumbled across
what they thought was a large rock in
the sand but upon further inspection
they realized it was a human skull along
with other human remains the park
rangers then responded to the scene and
set up a perimeter right now the clark
county coroner's office is working to
identify the remains today i spoke to a
retired henderson police officer david
kohlmeyer he tells us he spoke to the
two sisters and says he doesn't believe
the new remains have any relation to the
body found in a barrel
i believe it's four or five miles away
from the other location so it is a
different location from where the body
the barrel is located so again i do
believe it's a different spot i
definitely was surprised now it makes
you start thinking right like how many
other bodies will be recovered
if they found one in a barrel and one in
another area like how many bodies are
out there now
cole meyer and his partner are offering
five thousand dollars to those who find
additional bodies at the lake he says he
hopes the incentive brings hope and a
sense of closure to the families and
friends of these victims while assisting
local law enforcement in their efforts
and coming up later in our newscast
experts at the mop museum weigh in on
the remains found in a barrel in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now